we have good news this is
good news from the standpoint of being
less bad u.s weekly new
jobless claims are at their lowest level
since the start of the coronavirus
pandemic
there was a bigger than expected drop in
new unemployment claims that we learned
about yesterday
we are at a pandemic era low the
department of labor
released this information yesterday
morning the new jobless claims for the
week ending march 20
came in at 684 000. the expectation was
730
000 and um the
revised expectation was 781 000 so
almost
100 000 fewer initial jobless claims
than expected over the last week
continuing claims are down to 3.8
million 3.8 million
remaining unemployed versus the 4
million and 4.1 million that were
expected and revised
this is the first time new jobless
claims have been under 700
000 going back to mid-march of 2020
which is
the start of the pandemic and
really you know week to week the numbers
can kind of go up and down
what we want to look at is trends and
new lows and we are seeing both the
continuing downward trend
and a new low now uh this is not oh wow
everything's fixed that's fantastic it's
not that at all and we still have so
many different issues including
jobs that are coming back as part-time
that used to be full-time
and what's funny is the when the when a
democrat is in the white house
the right always says they're not
telling you this and this and this and
this
but i tell you this stuff all the time
there's reasons that these numbers are
not
glorious numbers and this only has some
to do with joe biden accelerating
vaccination
certainly is a factor but there's a
seasonality to this pandemic that is
similar in much of the world
i you know i have no interest in making
things partisan
when they don't particularly need to be
uh there's no doubt that there are some
jobs coming back as part-time rather
than full-time as businesses go from
being open a little bit to being fully
open hopefully in the next six months
some of those part-time jobs will become
full-time they won't all
um all all sorts of other caveats we've
not dealt with the minimum wage
there are still wage issues in general
but i think
if we are looking to kind of take a
cautiously optimistic approach on the
pandemic yesterday we saw that although
cases have stopped declining
hospitalizations are still declining
albeit more slowly deaths are still
declining
and vaccinations are increasing if we
think two to three months out as we get
into early summer
that's potentially a pretty good looking
situation
economically we are now starting to get
new analyses
from goldman sachs and i know many
people will say dave at goldman sachs
if you go back to the goldman sachs
analyses
of april 2020 in terms of vaccine
rollout
and economic numbers they were
i the most accurate i'm aware of they
correctly predicted approval for a
vaccine
in late october early november they
correctly predicted that you would start
to see health care workers vaccinated
towards the end of 2020 trump was saying
it would be way sooner
some doom and glooms were saying it
wouldn't be under until the middle of
2021
goldman sachs has been excellent on this
with their predictions
i'm not telling you go and get a goldman
financial advisor i'm not telling you
anything about
financial advisors but the golden
analysis is that
the end of 2021 particularly q4
is going to look very good by most of
the economic indicators that that we
look at so the point here
is much work to be done not the time to
start going crazy as they've been doing
in some spring break
hot spots but the economic numbers are
improving
the vaccination numbers are improving
and we're hoping that the blip in cases
is going to continue down over the next
two to three months
i am sure that i will get some
calls from viewers in the next segment
about
what is going on with vaccination and
the pandemic
let me know your thoughts on the
expected trajectory you can find me on
twitter
at d pacman and you can also find the
show on twitter
at david pakman show today's episode is
sponsored by
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for
free take a short quiz on the bluechew
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription
and the medication goes right to your
home in a discreet package no driving to
the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
bluechews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for free when you
use promo code pacman
just pay five dollars for shipping